The following content is provided under a
Creative Commons license. Your support will
help MIT Open CourseWare continue to offer
high-quality educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses, visit MIT Open
CourseWare at ocw.mit.edu.
I'm going to talk about alternate consensus
mechanisms. And there's a bunch of them. And
some of them are variants on proof of work.
Some of them are proof of stake-- all these
different things.
So unique node lists-- this is something that
Ripple and Stellar use. I'm not sure if there's
others. Proof of stake is this huge research
topic that lots of things fall under. There's
lots of variance. One of them I'll talk about
is delegated proof of stake.
Proof of space is an interesting thing that
is basically a form of proof of work that
doesn't use CPU as much. There's the idea
of directed acyclic graphs, which IOTA is
a great example of. And then one that I came
up with a few years ago and is kind of fun--
proof of idol, which is sort of silly but
some of these others are silly, too.
OK. And so disclaimer-- I'm OK with proof
of work. So I think if you were at the class
on Monday, it's a great segue into this, where,
clearly, proof of work has, I don't know if
you want to call it problems, but it's kind
of crazy, right, all the stuff David was saying
on Monday. It's not an egalitarian-- and I
think in the Satoshi White Paper, he says
one CPU, one vote.
Well, that's not really how it works. Define
CPU. Maybe you have your own CPU. Someone
else has a different view. And there's that
huge industry of building all these chips.
So there's a lot of issues with proof of work.
It's certainly not ideal.
That's probably not why most people don't
like it. So I, generally, in academia, in
a lot of business places, people don't like
the Bitcoin proof of work mechanism-- not
everyone, but it's a pretty widespread. Oh,
Bitcoin is bad because it uses as much electricity
as Denmark or something.
And I think that's a sort of early, I don't
like it because it uses electricity. There's
other reasons not to like it, which I think
you have to go into much more depth. Like
with David's talk yesterday, sure, it uses
a lot of electricity. But it also uses a lot
of fabrication plants, and it uses all these
other distribution networks. So anyway, I
get that there's a lot of-- one of the first
things with Bitcoin is, OK, how can we improve
upon this? How can we get rid of this huge
energy sink?
On the other hand, I'm sort of OK with it,
right? The first thing that I thought with
Bitcoin is, wow, this is going to be huge.
This is going to take a lot of electricity.
But it's kind of cool that it works that way.
So I'm sort of OK with people-- to me, you
can't really get mad at people doing things
you think are stupid because you'll just get
mad all the time. People mine gold. People
spend billions of dollars on diamonds. I think
diamonds are really stupid. But hey, if you
want to dig up diamonds, oh, whatever. Yeah.
There's entire cultural areas that I just
have no interest in. But hey.
OK. So I'll try to explain these other methods
in a neutral way. But I do have my own biases,
where I think like, hey, proof of work pretty
much works. I think it's a cool system. And
I'm somewhat skeptical of various different
algorithms and mechanisms here.
And also, I'm most familiar with the proof
of work system and all the intricacies of
it. So like with David's talk yesterday, there
was some new stuff, but I sort of knew because
I've talked to these people for a long time,
and this is how this system works.
Proof of stake-- I've seen it implemented
in altcoins. But I haven't followed them that
closely. So I don't know as intimately what
goes wrong and all the weird details. Anyway.
OK. So the first one, UNL, or unique node
list. This is, essentially, the consensus
mechanism used by Ripple and Stellar. For
history, Ripple started in 2013? No, 2011.
I don't know. It was a while ago.
AUDIENCE: [? Dennis ?] says [INAUDIBLE] January
1, 2013.
TADGE DRYJA: 2013, OK. So actually, the name
Ripple and the idea of these debt obligations
through this network actually predates Bitcoin.
And then Jed McCaleb started the company.
He's also the guy who started Mt. Gox. So
he started Mt. Gox, I believe, in 2011 or
'10-- late 2010, sold it to the Mark Karpelés,
started Ripple, hired a bunch of people, sort
of got fired from Ripple.
There's a lot of bad-- everyone fighting.
Because it was all these people who used to
play Magic-- the Gathering and were friends.
And now they're not friends anymore. And then,
he started Stellar, which he called "Secret
Bitcoin Project."
And I was thinking of joining it, but he wouldn't
tell me what it was. And also, I knew that
other people knew what it was, like my friends,
and if they weren't telling me because they're
not supposed to, it was like, well, it must
not be that cool. Because nobody can actually
keep a secret if it's really cool.
[LAUGHING]
So that was my, mm, I'll just go work somewhere
else. And Stellar was, more or less, a copy
of the Ripple code, which was open source,
so it was totally fine to do this. And then
it diverged, and they added their own
different parts of the consensus algorithm
than Ripple did.
So it's account-based, somewhat like Ethereum.
Transactions have senders, receivers. What's
interesting is in the Stellar case, and possibly
Ripple, there's a minimum balance. So I actually
had some Stellar last year, or up until last
year, because I went to the initial release
party, and they gave out Stellar. And I had
some.
And then, it wasn't much. But then, last year,
I looked, and it was like, oh, this is like
$200 worth. I'll sell it. And I sold it and
got some bitcoins. But it was weird because
they enforced a minimum balance, which seems
weird to me. Because you had to retain some
number of stellar units in every account,
which, to me, seems sort of weird.
Because that means those stellars, they're
gone, in a way, in that if you open a new
account and it must have 50 stellar in it
forever. Well, so Stellar effectively destroyed,
it just seemed-- which is a fine thing to
do. It's sort of a transaction fee. But from
a computer science database standpoint, it's
like, why not just have it cost money to create
a new account instead of have a minimum balance?
So just interacting with it, it was like,
huh.
So there's no work. But the idea is that nodes
sign transactions that they've seen. Everyone
makes blocks. And you sign them, so you've
got some kind of identity. Your node has a
key. When you start a new node, you've got
a public key/private key pair. You can sign
off on transactions.
This is not the case in Bitcoin, right? In
Bitcoin, you have a full node. Your full node
might have a wallet associated with it with
public keys and private keys, but the node
itself does not. Possibly in the future, there's
BIP 150, I believe, which the idea is to have
encrypted communications between nodes, which
would have some kind of authentication.
There's BIP and BIP 151. I might have them
backwards. 151, I believe, is just encryption,
so for privacy, confidentiality. And then,
BIT 150 is for authenticity. So you connect
to a node. You're like, oh, this is the same
node at the same IP address that I connected
to before. They're not implemented yet that
I'm aware of.
So right now, in Bitcoin, when you connect
to people, you just use their IP address.
You don't really know who they are. There's
no authentication there. But in these, in
Ripple and Stellar, you do know. OK. I'm connecting
to this node. It's got a key. It's got an
identity.
So to sync, instead of verifying all the work,
you verify the signatures on blocks. And the
question is, whose signatures, right? So if
you assume, OK, well, if we have a majority
that's honest and is not trying to create
transactions that are invalidated or something
like that, then it might work. But majority
is hard to define when you're subject to civil
attacks, right?
The obvious attack is I just make thousands
of nodes, or maybe these nodes don't even
really exist. I just make thousands of key
pairs, have them pretend to be nodes in my
own subnetwork, and they all endorse blocks
that are different than the rest of the network
is endorsing.
So majority is the tricky part. How do you
know who's the majority if you don't know
who these people are? You need some kind of
way to identify humans or computers, even.
And this is a problem akin to certificate
authorities.
So a lot of the problems that you see in blockchain,
bitcoin, these kind of things, are not exactly
new problems and have sort of already been,
quote unquote, "solved." So does everyone
know how CAs work, or do people have some
idea? Or who's like, what's a CA?
OK. So it's kind of interesting. I can give
a little demo.
AUDIENCE: Did you say CA stands for certificate
authority?
TADGE DRYJA: Yes. Uh-oh. This doesn't work.
Hold on. OK. So if you have a computer, I
don't know where it is in Windows, but I think
in Mac and Linux, it's in the same place.
You go to etc and then-- shoot, I forget where
it is. Yeah. Where's the certificates? Cert--
tru--
AUDIENCE: CA certificates right under the
mouse.
TADGE DRYJA: There it is. OK. So in your computer,
and whether you have Linux or Mac, you've
got a folder somewhere, etc/ca-certificates.
It's something like that in Mac, as well.
And, oh, no, that's not it. Where are they?
Shoot. Wait, wait, wait-- what is in update.dn?
And there's nothing there.
Hold on. I need to find this. Because this
is kind of cool. Where are X? Ah, SSL-- is
that-- there we go. OK. So sorry. etc/ssl,
and then you've got certs. And this folder
has a bunch of certs.
I trust all of these entities. Well, my computer
does and, by extension, my browsers and my
computer, which is crazy because I have no
idea who these people are. TURKTRUST? I don't
really trust Turkey. Swisscom-- Swiss people
seem nice, I guess. I don't know. OK. Staat--
they're in Netherlands somewhere.
There's a bunch of, just things you've never
heard of. Hellenic Academic and Research Institute,
Hong Kong Post. Well, Hong Kong Post Office
seems trustworthy. Yeah?
AUDIENCE: On the TURKTRUST one, you pointed
out they have [INAUDIBLE] certificates with
google.com when they're not supposed to. [INAUDIBLE].
TADGE DRYJA: And then, CNNIC is one which
is like-- is that still in here? Maybe they
got rid of it. And then some of them just
have these numbers, and you don't even know.
You have to go in.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
TADGE DRYJA: Yeah. China Internet Network
Information Center EB certificates root. I
actually really don't trust them to endorse--
pseudo arm-- there we go. OK, it's gone--
solved it, solved the distributed internet
trust problem.
AUDIENCE: Now part of the internet doesn't
work for you.
TADGE DRYJA: Yeah, well, I might get invalid
certificate errors for some Chinese sites
now. I don't go to many Chinese sites. Anyway,
so that's the basic idea of certificate authorities.
And this started in mid-'90s, when they wanted
to make public key infrastructure for secure
websites.
One of the problems is how do you know-- so
you've got-- oh, we didn't talk about Diffie-Hellman,
or maybe I mentioned it. But you've got public
keys, private keys. You've got ways to do
signatures. Diffie-Hellman is a way to do
key exchange. So if I know you're a public
key, and I give you my public key, we can
form a third, basically, key that we can then
use for encryption and secure messaging.
This works, but how do you know, given a key,
who is on the other end? So that's the idea
of certificate authorities. You have this
sort of root of trust. And these certificate
authorities sign certificates in websites
and let you know, oh, this is the person who
you think it is.
So for example, Google-- secure connection.
Really? How do I know? Verified by Google
Trust. Well, Google has verified that Google
is trustworthy, which is somewhat circular.
But no, that's sort of how it works. Yeah,
so Google Trust Services is a certificate
authority. And they signed off their own certificate
for their own website. That's maybe not the
best example.
OK, The New York Times, they are certified
by Comodo CA, who also has had-- Comodo has
gotten in a lot of trouble for signing the
wrong things. So yeah. New York Times does
not have an EB cert. I think Washington Post
does. So there's also EB certs where-- you've
got now The Washington Post, WP Company LLC.
That's like an extended validation cert, which,
then, the CA is saying, we didn't just check
that they had an IP address and a domain name.
We actually checked that they had some kind
of legal corporate entity. And they sent it
on their letterhead, and we, I don't know,
emailed someone in Delaware to make sure they
actually had a company. And this is verified
by Entrust. OK. So Entrust, Comodo, those
are all going to be in here. Yeah, there's
Comodo.
So you've got these companies called CAs that
have some kind of agreement with each other.
There's these standards where you make some
kind of standards where, OK, don't sign the
wrong thing. If you do, we're going to delete
you. And then they all endorse entities' identity,
usually for companies.
There's also stuff now-- Let's Encrypt, which
does it for free and without really endorsing
anything. This whole thing, it sort of felt
like it was like the big scam of the late
'90s because they made billions of dollars.
But then again, we got Ubuntu out of it, right?
So yeah, Ubuntu was funded by Mark Shuttleworth,
who started this one, I believe, and made
a couple hundred million, went on the spaceship,
went into orbit, had some fun. Eccentric billionaires
are what fund a lot of technology development.
And this is how we get them.
A lot of the people who work on Bitcoin and
these systems feel that the current-- it's
called X.509 is the name of this whole system
with these certificate authorities-- and I
also sort of feel that this is a suboptimal
solution in that there's a lot of problems
with certificates being signed inappropriately.
It works, in a way. But it's not great.
So this is a problem. So the problem that
these systems like Ripple and Stellar have
to deal with are, in some ways, similar to
the problem that is solved by CAs. So what
they do is they say, we have a unique node
list. We're not actually endorsing an identity
from, here's a public key, here's a human
name or a company name or something like that.
It's we're just saying that they're unique.
So it's more limited than a certificate authority.
It's just saying we're certifying that these
two keys belong to different people or different
companies, which seems easier than the job
of a CA, right? The CA has to verify that
The Washington Post is actually-- whoever's
presenting a public key is actually The Washington
Post. So the actual certificate is just, basically,
here's a pubkey, here's a name, and then the
CA sign. And you can look at those and stuff.
OK. So for synchronization, you wait for a
majority of nodes in your unique node list
to sign and, if they've signed, accept. So
there's some recent papers from Ripple. And
in order to really get consensus, you need,
basically, a 90% overlap in your own unique
node list.
So if I have a unique node list of Alice and
Bob and Carol, and you have a unique node
list of Carol and Dave and Edna-- I don't
know-- we might diverge. We might not agree
on the same chain of transactions because
we've got different people that were looking
at their signatures. They may all be unique.
But if we have different unique people we're
looking to, it might not converge.
So they have a newer paper that reduces that
to 60%-ish, where the overlap of what unique
nodes everyone needs to look at is not as
large but still quite large. And then, the
real question is, OK, well, who provides the
unique node list? Because that's not really
a job I can do.
Maybe it is, in a way. If I know you, and
we do some kind of web of trust thing where
I'm like, oh, what's your Ripple nodes pubkey?
OK. Cool, I know you. And what's your Ripple
nodes pubkey? We meet in person. We sign each
other's pubkeys. We do the whole PGP kind
of thing, which I do. And the Bitcoin people
actually do this.
So if I go to-- hold on. So I've got a bunch
of keys, and everyone signed them. And there's
Andrew Chow and Suhas and [INAUDIBLE] and
all these Bitcoin people. And I've signed
their keys and they've signed my keys because
we meet in person and do that kind of thing.
So we've established not just a unique node
list, but we've done a CA-free validation
of each other's keys. We just meet in person,
read each other's keys off.
So you can do that, in practice. It's really
nerdy, and no one does that. And it would
be cool if we could get it to be easier and
maybe cooler somehow. But it's been an uphill
battle.
So who provides the UNL? It's probably kind
of obvious. Well, the Ripple company provides
the UNL, right? So when you download Ripple,
it has a list of unique nodes. Those are essentially
de facto, the nodes that run Ripple. And at
the current time, those nodes are run by the
Ripple corporation, or Ripple apps.
Stellar, similarly, it comes with a default
UNL. It sort of acts like the CAs, right?
It's sort of how when you start your computer,
you've got this. This comes with your OS.
And you don't really have a choice. I just
deleted the CNNIC one. But nobody looks at
this stuff. Everyone just goes with the defaults.
So that's the problem centralization-wise.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: You said Ripple or Stellar actually
run the nodes? Because I understand that they
might sign off on the UNL if you're saying
that--
TADGE DRYJA: In Ripple's-- at least a year
or two ago, and they may have changed that,
I think they're trying to-- but in Ripple's
case, yeah. They ran their own Ripple nodes.
AUDIENCE: So it's not these bank partners
or anything?
TADGE DRYJA: They may have some. They may
now. But I know that two years ago, it was
just Ripple, or majority Ripple. Because they
also put in things like they can freeze funds.
Because Ripple got in trouble with FinCEN.
And part of the thing is they modified their
code to be able to freeze people's funds if
they did something bad.
That's definitely not something that the Bitcoin
developers, or even the Ethereum Foundation--
it's not as direct, anyway. The Ethereum Foundation
did freeze funds and move them against the
rules of the system in the case of the Dow.
But that was, in a lot of ways, with support
of a lot of the people running Ethereum. With
Ripple, they can do it without much brouhaha.
They just freeze these funds.
So it's fast. There's no work involved. There's
no worry about propagating blocks and miners
getting advantages. But there's also known
identities, and so it's more susceptible to
subpoenas and things like that.
In these cases, all the coins existed at the
genesis block. So in the case of Ripple, I
think it was 100 billion or something. And
they just started with all the coins and distributed
them as they saw fit.
Same with Stellar. Stellar had this thing
where they had this party, and they would
give them away if you signed up on Facebook.
A really interesting article about people
in Manila getting thousands of used SIM cards
from the US, registering for new Facebook
accounts, selling those Facebook accounts
to people in China, the people in China then
registering with Stellar as unique people
to get more stellars.
When you incentivize things, weird things
happen, be it either giant warehouses full
of SHA256 chips or giant warehouses full of
20-year-old girls in Manila putting SIM cards
in cell phones all day. Yeah. I should link
to that article. It's really interesting.
So anyway, this is the Stellar one. And Stellar
also had this thing where they were going
to give 20% of the stellar to people who held
bitcoin, sort of an airdrop. I didn't get
any from that. I was sort of hoping. I'm like,
hey, cool-- air drop. I have bitcoin. I'll
get some stellar. I didn't because you basically
had to KYC with them.
They said, OK, send in your-- I don't know
if it was the social security number-- but
send in your documents and prove that you
have these bitcoins, and we will credit some
stellar to the same keys. And I'm not going
to do that. Yeah. Some people did. Some people
got some stellar that way. Yeah. So anyway.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: If Stellar's just freezing coins--
TADGE DRYJA: No. I don't know if Stellar has
that capability. Ripple does. Ripple put that
in. Stellar is a different-- it's similar
software. They certainly argue about how different
they are.
Stellar had a bug in 2015, I believe, where
the consensus broke. And then they said, oh,
it's Ripple's code's fault. This is a fault
with all this code base. And then Ripple said,
no, no, no. It's because you changed it. And
you don't know what you're doing.
AUDIENCE: I was talking about, I guess, the
minimums. You said there was a minimum.
TADGE DRYJA: Yeah, there's a minimum account
balance.
AUDIENCE: And if there's a set number of coins,
then eventually, accounts will just get--
TADGE DRYJA: Yeah. It's a lot, though. Also,
there's enough forever. There's a lot of coins.
But yeah. But the idea is not that you have
UTXOs, like in Bitcoin, and you make new addresses
each time. The idea is you have an address.
You keep that forever. So why would you have
multiple different addresses, that kind of
thing.
Anyway. So it's a pretty different system.
In some ways, you could argue it's one of
the first ICOs-- Ripple-- because it was pretty
early. They just came up with all their coins
and gave them out and then started selling
them. And they continue to do that to this
day.
Stellar is a nonprofit, which is also sort
of weird. Because if you make a billion dollars
off of something, is it really a nonprofit?
I don't know. The organization didn't directly
make the money and then pay it to the employees
or anything. But the people who have all the
stellar tokens made a lot of money. Interesting
sort of ways to do it.
So I think both Ripple and Stellar argue that
it's decentralized, distributed. But I think
a lot of people say, well, maybe to some extent.
But on the spectrum of completely decentralized
versus one server handles it all, it's a lot
further on the centralized side.
And Bitcoin is also kind of centralized, too,
like we were talking about on Monday. But
I would argue these are more so. So anyway.
Any questions about Ripple, Stellar? Pretty
fun.
OK. Next, the big one-- proof of stake. So
this we've mentioned a little bit. It's a
popular alternative where people really don't
like the proof of work stuff. So instead of
proving work, have the people who hold coins
sign the blocks. So that bootstraps, in a
way, your unique node list or your list of
who's who.
Well, you don't really care who they are.
But if they have coins, if you already have
a set of who owns what coins, you can use
that to say, OK, well, the people who own
coins now signed. And they, presumably, have
incentives not to destroy the network they
have coins in.
So if you have a given genesis block with
some kind of initial distribution, you can
make it deterministic. You can say, I'm just
going to go with whatever has the most stake,
whoever has the most coins, signing off on
the next block. And given two or three different
histories, you can see, OK, from the start,
which has the most total stakes signing off
on these things? So that seems pretty cool.
Here's some issues. Stake grinding-- so for
example, let's say you have a system where
the signer of the next block is determined
by the public key nearest to the previous
block hash. So for example, OK, I'm looking
at the current block hash. Who gets to sign
next? Well, whoever's key is closest. Use
X or just treat the hash as a number and treat
the pubkey as a number and see which is closest.
You can do that. But the problem is if the
next hash is determined by the current signer,
that current signer can make a new signature
each time and try to make sure that the block
after is also going to be one where they are,
again, the next signer. And they can make
a couple hundred different accounts with their
keys and then keep grinding stake.
And this basically means that it turns into
proof of work. Because if you can influence
who's going to be the next block signer--
yourself-- keep trying different ways to sign,
OK, that's basically proof of work, but instead
of hashing, you're signing.
And this has happened in many altcoins. One
that I think was kind of interesting was Nxt,
which is the people who later went on to make
IOTA. They said, OK, well, we have a deterministic
signature scheme, and so this can't happen,
right? Given a message and a private key,
there's only one signature that can be produced.
And this is true. So Bitcoin uses this. It's
called rfc6979. Basically, the random nonce
can be deterministically created from your
private key and message.
The problem is-- I don't know if they realized,
probably not-- but you can't enforce this.
It's a policy that says, OK, I'm going to
make a deterministic signature. But given
a signature, you can't tell if someone did
this or not, right? So it's up to you to obey
this rule. But you can't verify that anyone
did it.
So that one also quickly devolved into proof
of work and in a tricky way because a lot
of people read the documentation and said,
OK, well, there is no way to keep signing.
Their function that they wrote, there's only
one way to sign. When you sign a message with
a public key, you get a single signature.
But people who knew how it worked under the
hood said, oh, I can change this code. It
will still be accepted as a valid signature
even though I'm using a different signing
scheme. So this is one issue, stake grinding.
There's ways to get around it.
So let's say you make it deterministic. You
have some way to enforce that a signer can
only create one message. There are certain
signature schemes where you can verifiably
make sure that a single key can only make
a single signature on a message.
Other ways to do it is to, say, have this
big lead time, where the people who are signing
the next block are determined by entropy created
days or weeks ago. So it's hard to know what's
going to happen in a week because it's a long
period of time's worth of entropy going into
it.
OK. There's another issue with proof of stake
called nothing at stake. So rehash-- rehash--
ha ha. So in proof of work, this happens,
right? This happens just by accident, where
OK, there's a block. And then two people are
mining on top of it. Oh, they both got this
and then sometimes even this. That almost
never happens in Bitcoin, but sometimes, where
you just randomly get two split chains coming
out at the same time.
But then this happens, right? Someone builds
on this one. OK, you get rid of those two.
And that's just because this is a random process.
You can mine on whichever you want. One of
them is going to happen first.
You can mine on both. You can split your hash
bar. If you have a billion hashes per second,
you can say, well, I'll do 500 million here
and 500 million here. You can equivocate.
It's sort of equivocation that way. But one
of them will finish first, with very high
probability. So eventually, this happens.
And then everyone just starts building off
this 00a3.
Proof of stake-- so this happens. Also, notice
that the hashes don't-- they don't start with
zeros. So this happens. But then this happens.
And then this happens. And then it just keeps
going. Because why not sign both, right?
I don't know which one's going to win, right?
As a proof of stake miner or staker, I don't
really know which one's going to win, which
is the same case and proof of work. In proof
of work, I just flip a coin and pick, right?
I don't know what's going to win.
I think in bitcoin, the default is go with
the one I saw first. Because whatever. It
doesn't matter who wins, right? Basically,
I win, whichever I pick. If I'm the next one
making the block, I win.
But what I don't want is I don't want to be
this this-- wait a sec. What I don't want
to be in proof of work is I don't want to
be 008a, right? I don't want to be the last
one to make a block, and then something else
comes out here.
So I'd rather be 00f2. But you don't know
here, right? So you just pick one. OK. Well,
we lost. In proof of stake, you don't have
to worry about that. I'll just build both,
right? It takes me no work to sign. So I just
sign off on both of them and make parallel
chain. And then everyone just keeps doing
that. Because if I pick one, I might be wrong.
If I pick both, I can't be wrong.
So this is a problem called nothing at stake.
You have no risk here. You're not actually
doing any work. You might as well just keep
going. So yeah. Faced with two blocks, why
not sign both?
So the mitigations-- one of the ideas early
in Ethereum was, OK, this thing called Slasher,
where if you can prove that a signature from
a different chain-- so the idea is on chain
00a3-- oh, wait-- oops. Sorry. On this chain,
you say, hey, look. This guy equivocated.
He signed off on two blocks, one of which
exists in my history that I can point to,
one of which doesn't exist in my history,
but I can provide that signature. I can say,
look, here's two signatures at the same block
height from the same person, but they're signing
different things. Let's not invalidate this
block, but let's take all the rewards from
the person who signed.
OK. So yeah. This is called Slasher. I believe
in Ethereum, like, 2014, they were saying,
hey, we're going to do proof of stake. And
then they tried all these things and sort
of, oh, it's non-trivial. Let's start with
proof of work, and then we'll move to proof
of stake later. And that's currently their
plan. So this was one of their early algorithms,
their early ideas.
There's also issues with the mitigation because
maybe it's hard to get this proof into the
blockchain. Because the miners, or the stakers,
are the ones who determine what gets in and
what doesn't.
And so they certainly could say, look, if
the person who created this block then sees
in this block that there's a Slasher proof
where, hey, I just now proved that you equivocated
and destroy your account, well, the person
who signed this doesn't build on this and
instead forks off and builds their own, right?
Why would I continue to mine on a chain where
I just lost all my money?
So there's all sorts of weird-- and there's
mitigations for that. So it's a little bit
whack-a-mole, where there's all these weird
problems, and you have to try to fix them.
And then fixing them introduces new weird
things. So there's a lot of people working
on it.
Yeah. Long-range attacks is another big one.
Let's say you go back to the genesis block,
and you rewrite history. In Bitcoin, you can
also do this. It's just really hard, right?
You could say, I'm going to get a bunch of
miners, rewrite all nine years of Bitcoin's
blocks, and we know exactly how long that
will take.
sipa has a nice graph of it, I think. And
sometimes it's not very long. Sometimes it's
actually pretty easy to do that. Yeah, that's
the other site. Hash rate-- this-- wait--
yes. Bitcoin network proof of work equivalent
days. That's this year. This is since the
beginning.
What this means is, OK, given the current
hash rate in Bitcoin, how long would it take
to rewrite the entire history of Bitcoin?
Because the hash rate goes up, right? And
sometimes it goes up in-- so this is the all-time
hash rate. It basically always looks like
this because it's exponential. So if you looked
at it three years ago, it would look pretty
much the same.
And then this is a log chart. So this actually
does show some interesting detail, where,
OK, this is when the GPUs came out. This is
when nothing much happened in 2012. This is
when ASICs came out. And then it just keeps
going up. And this is log scale, where each
number is 100 or 1,000 times. So it's big.
So when you have these really sharp upticks,
like in mid-2010, the current power of the
network is so high-- that probably corresponds
to this, the lowest point there, because that's
the steepest slope, where I don't know what
this is, a week?-- you could rewrite the entire
history of Bitcoin in a week and destroy everyone's
currency and have all the coins yourself if
you had enough power under your control, which
you could probably do.
And today, it sits at around 200, a little
less than 200, so a little over six months
where, if you devoted all the current hash
power, you could rewrite all the previous
history. Still, six months-- it's a lot. And
it's interesting how this changes. This is,
I guess, when the ASICs first came out, and
then the slope [INAUDIBLE].
So that is an issue in proof of work that
can happen. It's not clear what would happen.
The software, at least in theory, the idea
is if something like that happens, where there's
a reorg that spans nine years, well, extend
this out to 500,000 and say, OK, all the stuff
you've been dealing with the last nine years,
it's out. We've got this new history now with
one person owning all the money, presumably.
The software will do that, probably, or it'll
just crash or something. It's sort of seen
as like, well, if there's a reorg that spans
weeks or months, the whole system's broken,
kind of. But probably.
So this is an issue for Bitcoin. But it's
a big issue in proof of stake because it seems
possibly more feasible, right? In Bitcoin,
there have been times when it's like, whoa,
a week, yeah, that's feasible, whereas right
now, it's like, OK, it would take all the
hash power in existence maybe seven or eight
months. So that means that Bitcoin would just
halt for seven months, and then you'd see
this reorg happen. And also, it assumes 51%
of the miners are doing this.
However, proof of stake, it might not be that
expensive, especially if you can get old keys.
So if you've got the keys from the genesis
block in this proof of stake currency, you
can rewrite a history from those with different
transactions. So yeah. So a lot of the times,
the solution is, OK, well, delete old keys
and assume 50% honest.
That's tricky. Because old keys can be sold.
And I know that people have asked, hey, can
I buy your old Ethereum keys? Why do you want
these? Well, if proof of stake happens, they
might be worth something. Currently, if you
have keys that are for addresses or accounts
that don't have any money anymore, it's not
very useful but possibly can be sold. Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Most proof of work schemes that
I'm aware of use a [INAUDIBLE].
TADGE DRYJA: A proof of stake?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
TADGE DRYJA: Yeah. So you checkpoint it. So
basically, to prevent long-range attacks,
the developers, usually, in GitHub, will just
say, OK, well, the block hash here is this.
And so you can't reorg before that. But then,
what's the mechanism for that? If it's the
developers just sticking in a checkpoint,
that's not really decentralized.
AUDIENCE: In the example of Aircoin, there's
actually a checkpointing [? software ?] that,
every few hours, forces a [INAUDIBLE].
TADGE DRYJA: OK. Well, that's even more not
very decentralized. You've now got a pubkey
hardcoded into the code, which then calls
out to somewhere and says, OK, what's the
correct block to be on? And then that key
signs something, says, oh, go here. OK. Yeah.
That's pretty centralized.
So this is one that I think is-- it's hard,
right? Because before these things happen,
it's easy to dismiss as like, this is crazy.
That's never going to happen. Who's going
to go back and buy up all these old keys that
people were supposed to have deleted? People
probably did delete them. You can't assume
that they haven't.
And even if they did and you made this big
reorg, well, everyone would know in practice
that that's not the right chain, similar to
if there's a nine-year block reorg in Bitcoin,
everyone would know, OK, come on. We all knew
what the blocks were yesterday. You can't
just tell me there's this entirely new history
today.
And in practice, that's probably true, right?
If there was a nine-year block reorg in Bitcoin,
probably, people would just ignore it. Similarly,
in these systems, probably, they would ignore
it. But it's harder to reason about in these
systems, I think.
But anyway. So proof of stake, there is a
bunch of coins that use it. In a lot of cases,
they have centralization that's hidden in
certain ways. I like the term Greg Maxwell
came up called trust laundering. It's not
money laundering. It's trust laundering. You
sort of move where you're trusting and try
to hide it.
Yeah. So very common. But this also deals
with, OK, who gets the initial coins? Because
they have an enormous power over the system.
So very common for altcoins-- less so now,
I think-- was start with proof of work, then
transition to proof of stake. Do they still?
Not as much.
AUDIENCE: Now you don't need to do that because
you [INAUDIBLE].
TADGE DRYJA: Right. So you just do ERC-20.
Yeah. But it used to be, like 2014, 2015,
a lot of the coins would be, OK, proof of
work for the first month, two months, whatever
it was, with some weird algorithm and Comodo
gravity well and all sorts of weird stuff.
And then it would switch at a certain point
to proof of stake.
So that proof of work period builds out the
list of who owns what in a sort of provable
way. And then, from there, you can use proof
of stake. Because you've got a, hopefully,
fairly well distributed set of who owns what.
Yeah. Some things still do this. And some
things have hybrid, where you still have to
do work each block. But depending on how much
stake you have, depending on how many coins
you have, you have to do less work.
I think decred is something like that. That
actually can make sense. Because you've still
got work, and you can mix them in ways that
negate some of the downsides of both.
Delegated proof of stake. Well, signing requires
you to actually do something and be online.
So in a lot of proof of stake currencies,
very few people actually stake because they
don't care. And they leave money on the table,
sure. But they don't want to run their own
node. They don't want to deal with this stuff.
They just buy it, keep it on exchange, or
maybe keep it on their own computer.
So instead, you can endorse a leader by signing
with your coins and saying, hey, I'm not going
to actually sign off on blocks, but I'll sign
off on a different key, who now can sign on
my behalf. And so this can be called supernodes,
masternodes. And then is it peer-to-peer,
or is it client server is what it becomes.
So the current one that's pretty popular is
called EOS, where I think they're doing this
kind of thing. And they're like, well, there's
20 computers that run the network. And you
can endorse one of them, and they'll give
you some kind of profit back or something.
And you need a million dollars to run one
of these computers. Because it's going to
be super powerful, and you can do free transactions
that way.
So this gets pretty far into client server
territory, where you're not up here. You're
just the client, and you ask them what is
going on, which, in many cases, works, right?
But then again, it's not quite as interesting
because that's sort of the system we already
have with banks. So meh.
But in a lot of cases, yeah, that's what people
want. I sort of joke that I should just make
one called Central Coin, where there's just
a nice server, and it just keeps track of
who owns what, and then have an ICO. And people
would use it. It's like, hey. So I think people
would be into it. Anyway, so that's distributed
proof of stake.
OK. So proof of stake, in general, it's hard
to resolve conflicts using only the system
itself. Proof of work has this really nice
property where it's taking something from
the external world, be it CPU time, be it
chips, and using that to get a dead reckoning
on the system itself. That's nice.
Proof of stake, the really difficult part
is it's a closed system. You're trying to
resolve conflicts within the system using
no external data. That's really hard.
Another problem people complain about is that
the rich get richer. I agree it's a problem.
It kind of sucks. But proof of work is the
same. I don't feel like any of these systems
will change the inherent Pareto distribution
of wealth in the universe. That just seems
to be how things work. It'd be cool if everyone
had the same amount of money, I guess, maybe.
But I don't think it's going to happen.
Yeah. And then it relies on different assumptions.
So the assumption in Bitcoin is 51% of miners
can destroy the system. So in some cases,
people say, well, you assume 51% honest in
Bitcoin. Kind of. It's more like 51% rational.
In Bitcoin, you could have miners with 51%
attack the system, but they make more money
by doing the right thing.
So there are certain cases in proof of stake
where honesty is not as profitable. And if
honesty is not profitable, well, maybe there's
a lot more incentive to be not honest in the
terms of the system, whereas in Bitcoin, it's
like you've got this nice system where it
seems like the honesty is not just enforced
by people trying to be nice. It's enforced
by people being greedy, which seems more common
than being nice in the world.
So there's tons of research in proof of stake.
Some of it's pretty interesting, pretty clever.
I'm not super hopeful. But the thing is it
works until it doesn't. And so it's really
hard to show security under different attacks.
So what I would worry about is you've got
this proof of stake system. It seems to be
working. And then something weird happens.
And it's revealed as, oh, actually, this was
a lot more centralized than it seemed to be,
which is also a worry in proof of work. OK.
Any questions, proof of stake? Yes?
AUDIENCE: A quick one on the economics. Is
the stake the nodes have. Yeah, right. So
in essence, if it was on EOS, it's how many
eos coins you have.
TADGE DRYJA: Yes, yes.
AUDIENCE: So then there's probably some economics
where people who are not miners will lend
their stake to get a return.
TADGE DRYJA: Basically, yeah. And a lot of
coins, the majority of the coins, are held
on different exchanges. And so that means
the exchanges would possibly be able to then
stake and get some kind of revenue.
AUDIENCE: Right. So they would be taking their
customer funds that are in wallets-- they
would have to be, probably, hot wallets--
and then the exchanges would have a leg up
to be the miners.
TADGE DRYJA: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Or a [INAUDIBLE].
TADGE DRYJA: Yeah. And so that's also an issue,
that there's all different ways to mitigate.
And you can say, oh, I'm in an exchange, but
I get to sign and delegate my stake to someone
else. And then I get some kind of revenue
sharing from that.
But yeah. It's also tricky, how do you incentivize
it in terms of how much new coins get issued
to the people staking? If it's zero, then
there's no real incentive to do it. You could
have a lot of different chain ports.
If it's very high, then it's very, I don't
know, Gini net curve goes way crazy because
the rich really get richer. Because the more
coins you have, you have an enormous amount
of revenue. So you need a balance there that's
also a bit difficult, economically.
That's also a problem in proof of work. I
feel like one of the big issues with Bitcoin
is half the coins came out in the first four
years, where hardly anyone was aware of it.
And that makes people not want to adopt the
system. Because it's like, well, wait. You
guys just got all this coin for, basically,
free. You were just running your computer
in 2011. I'm not going to be part of that
system.
So I feel like it would have been nicer if
it was more of an S curve and less of a log
curve. Because then, maybe it would ramp up
to 2015, and then lots of coins were coming
out. But anyway.
So Ripple or Stellar are sort of an extreme
case of that, where all the coins were initially
made by one entity. And so to me, I'm like,
I don't want these. That's your money. You
just made it up yourself.
I don't know. It just feels like kids being
like, I have a bazillion dollars, and I write
a bazillion dollars. It's like, OK. Well,
you just wrote that. I'm not going to honor
that.
Anyway. OK. So proof of stake, kind of interesting.
Proof of space, there's a bunch of ideas here.
Some of them-- SpaceMint was some people here.
I know Bram Cohen, who is the author of BitTorrent,
right-- he made BitTorrent whatever 10, almost
15 years ago now-- he's now working on some
of these kind of things.
He's working on a proof of space coin called
Chia. And the idea, it's still similar to
proof of work. But you're using some kind
of memory or storage space, rather than your
CPU. And the idea is the benefit is, well,
maybe it doesn't use as much electricity.
And also, from talking to Bram with his, he's
saying there's much more dead storage space
than dead CPU. So every computer has a CPU,
but the CPU here is not that powerful. It
can't really compete with ASICs. But lots
of people have empty hard drive space.
And you might have a terabyte of empty hard
drive space, and one terabyte's as good as
another. And it's also empty is what you need.
Because you need to fill in space for these
systems.
And so if you're like, well, I'm AWS, I've
got tons of hard drives-- right, but people
are using them. So you're not able to then
just fill it in for these kinds of systems--
well, to some extent. They do have a lot of
slack, and they can probably do it. But several
ideas. Some are pretty cool.
So one example-- this is sort of an example
idea. It's not fully fleshed out, but to give
you an idea. So you buy a 10-terabyte drive,
OK? You precompute 100 billion key pairs.
And this takes a long time. And this is work,
right? You're doing 100 billion computations
of coming up with the random private key,
multiplying by G, getting the pubkey.
And you store it in a key-value store, like
a database-- LevelDB or something-- on your
hard drive. And the key is the pubkey. And
the value is the private key. So you remember
your key pairs. But you've sorted it in a
way so that you can quickly go through the
pubkeys, right? So you have logins, search
time, some kind of binary tree-- whatever
it is-- in your database.
And so then, the idea is, to create the next
block, you want the key closest to the current
block hash can sign. So a valid proof of work--
you have some threshold, maybe-- a valid proof
of work is whoever's got a key that's very
close to this, they're able to sign. And those
keys do not exist on the network prior to
the signing procedure. They exist just hidden
on people's hard drives.
And so the idea is you could just try to keep
computing keys till you find one and then
sign with it. And that would just make it
completely proof of work. So it is proof of
work. But the idea is you can precompute.
You can do all the work beforehand.
And then you can use that precomputed proof
of work later on and possibly multiple times.
In practice, it's not going to be multiple
times. Because you've got 100 billion, and
you're never going to use the same key twice.
The idea is everyone does this, right? So
you have trillions, quadrillions, however
many keys out there that everyone's generated.
And every block that comes out, someone will
say, ah, I was lucky, and I made a key that
can now sign the next block.
So it's work, but it's amortized over weeks,
months, years. And it's basically how big
is your storage. If you have a lot of storage,
you can precompute a lot of this stuff and
then use it. So it's kind of a cool system.
There's other asterisks that actually get
a little more complex because you need some
timing mechanisms, as well. But I think it's
a cool idea. Hard drives then maybe get more
expensive instead of graphics cards getting
more expensive. I don't know.
But the idea is like, yeah. You use the work
but later on. So I don't know. Any questions
about that one? Kind of cool. There's a SpaceMint--
it's a cool paper-- about how to do this cryptographically.
And then Chia is another one doing this kind
of idea. I like it because it doesn't really
change the assumptions of proof of work, right?
It is still a form of proof of work. But instead
of burning electricity, you're using hard
drives. Kind of cool.
AUDIENCE: Wouldn't you still have the same
issues, like you'd have to have ASICs just
filling racks and racks and racks of hard
drives for keys. Is it different?
TADGE DRYJA: You already have that, right?
There's server farms where they're just storage
farms, and they just have tons of hard drives.
So that's already a thing.
AUDIENCE: But I'm saying it isn't any different.
You'd still be-- it would be [INAUDIBLE]--
TADGE DRYJA: I guess the idea is the economies
of scale are not quite as bad in that hard
drives are already, basically, optimal at
doing this. And if you can make a system that's
better at doing this, you've just made a better
hard drive, which, hey, great. You made a
better hard drive. Everyone can use it. So
I guess the idea is it's not as specific because
it's just, hey, store a bunch of data and
then [? seq ?] quickly through it.
AUDIENCE: It still seems CPU-bound, right,
compute-bound.
TADGE DRYJA: No. Once you generate this--
OK, generating this is compute-bound, right?
You need to populate your 10 terabyte drive.
But that might only take a few hours, right?
To make 100 billion key pairs, I'm guessing
less than a day, right? Yeah. And you can
do that in parallel. So you make it. And then
once you've made it, you leave it there. And
then you're going to be able to mine with
that forever.
AUDIENCE: But see, the winner would be whoever
can fill the most number of keys per second
going forward.
TADGE DRYJA: But you need something to fill.
I think the hard drive cost is much higher
than the cost to fill it, right? Because a
10 terabyte hard drive is going to be, like,
$200. And with a cheap CPU, you can fill a
10 terabyte hard drive every few hours. So
yeah, the CPU is a factor, but I think it's
going to be smaller. Yeah?
AUDIENCE: At least from what I understand
about SpaceMint, the idea is to make it not
I/O bound [INAUDIBLE]. So if I have a better
or faster hard drive, that's not [INAUDIBLE].
It's just [? another ?] space.
TADGE DRYJA: Because yeah. This is just a
seq, right? And even a crummy hard drive,
you just read through your binary trainer.
You're like, oh, found it.
AUDIENCE: I think the point is that you're
only supposed to do one with those pub [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: Yes. [INAUDIBLE].
TADGE DRYJA: So you look at, OK, here's the
current block hash. What do I have that's
close? Seq to that on my drive. Nope. I'm
not going to win this one. OK. Let someone
else do it. Or you seq, and you find it. You're
like, hey, cool. I can sign. Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Is this also known as proof of space
and time?
TADGE DRYJA: Yeah. So in Chia, they add this
time component, which I'm not 100% clear on
how it works. It's changed a little bit. But
the idea of a time beacon is you want some
function that cannot be parallelized so that
if you have 100 computers doing it, it's not
going to be any faster than one computer doing
it. So basically, whoever's got the fastest
single CPU will always win this. And that
can be a time beacon for these space things.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Once you start to have a lot of
storage, if you're in a search will find [INAUDIBLE],
do you kind of go back to-- you're almost
getting hurt. [INAUDIBLE] So what I'm saying,
you're just doing the same thing again?
TADGE DRYJA: I think that's a [INAUDIBLE].
If you have tons of hard drives, and you want
tons of key values, and you just want to find
one or find the closest match, you can do
that in log n time, even over a whole data
center. Google, you just search, and it's
like, hey. It comes up in a fraction of a
second.
So that's doable. You need good software,
and you need a good infrastructure to do it.
But I think it's doable. It scales pretty
well, I think.
But yeah, it has the same issues where you
just end up with people buying a whole bunch
of hard drives. And what are the economies
of scale there? There's arguments that it
might be better than the economies of scale
with, like, ASICs, that we heard about on
Monday. Maybe not. I don't know. We'll see
if this takes off. It's fairly new. It's an
idea that's been talked about for a few years.
AUDIENCE: It's [INAUDIBLE] space. And they've
been around for years in this [INAUDIBLE].
TADGE DRYJA: OK. Well, so there's different
ideas. I don't know. It seems like one of
the more interesting. There's cool math and
cool crypto involved. OK. So it'll work but
amortized.
So and perennial MIT favorite, IOTA, they
use a directed acyclic graph. And now, a chain
is also a DAG. Because it's directed. There's
no cycles. It's a graph. But it's a pretty
simple one. But the ideas have multiple parents,
right?
So if you have a block, instead of just pointing
to one, you could say, well, now, this can
happen in Bitcoin, right, where you've got
two blocks, both supporting the same thing.
But this cannot happen in Bitcoin, where you
say, oh, I'm coming off, and I'm referring
to both of these. But in a directed acyclic
graph, you can do that.
So Ethereum actually does it. I think Joe
Bonneau was mentioning that. And so what happens
is you endorse one as the correct one and
one as the uncle. So you're saying, no, this
is the real one. But I also saw this one.
And give this one a little bit of money, right,
maybe not the whole reward they were hoping
for. But they get something.
And so then, something like IOTA says, OK,
we have lots. And every node points to two
previous. And so you get this whole map. They
could even point to different heights. So
I can point to here and here. I don't really
know why you'd do this.
So there's some ways it could reduce latency,
right? So one of the trade-offs in Bitcoin
is 10-minute block time seems fairly arbitrary.
It's kind of slow. Latency-- people don't
like latency because they have to wait. Fine.
The more important metric, I think, is that
it leads to miner centralization and miner
pools. Because if there's only 144 blocks
a day, like in Bitcoin, if you have a millionth
of the hash power of the network, you're just
never going to find anything, right?
If you're just mining on your own, over the
course of a year, you're probably not going
to find a single block, and you'll have wasted
all of that effort. So instead, you join a
pool and try to pool with other people to
distribute those rewards.
However, if there's, like in Ethereum, a block
every 15 seconds, and there's millions of
blocks that come out, if you have a millionth
of the hash power, you might find a block.
The blocks have smaller rewards, but chopping
it up more finely is a nice way to do it.
So like P2Pool, which you were gone, is a
way to try to make that. And it's important
to get it more decentralized. But it's hard.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: P2Pool does that?
TADGE DRYJA: Yeah. Yeah. P2Pool sort of does
this as a layer on top. So it could help latency.
And then, it could help reduce the amount
of orphans in the blockchain, which then helps
miner centralization. So there are interesting
ideas for it.
But it doesn't help scalability at all, right?
It actually hurts scalability. Because now
I have to keep track of all these things instead
of just one chain. And I'm going to have to
keep track of all the data, anyway, if I've
got the UTXO set. I can't just ignore parts
of it.
So it doesn't help scalability at all. And
in the case of IOTA, their custom ternary
hash functions also don't help much, either.
So that was what we wrote about last year.
They made all their own weird stuff. I don't
know.
So there are interesting ideas between directly
acyclic graphs. But it feels like when they
say, hey, this is more scalable, I get very
suspicious. Because it doesn't seem to help
scalability. It does possibly help some other
things. Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Is, effectively, Bitcoin refreshing
[? test? ?] They've made it so every block
has min difficulty. And so the transactions
are instant because, right, it doesn't change--
TADGE DRYJA: What, in IOTA, or in--
AUDIENCE: In any of these stack coins. So
it doesn't cost much to make a new block and
make a transaction. And if everyone's competing
to do that, then they're just another ton
of orphans, and [INAUDIBLE].
TADGE DRYJA: Yeah, yeah. So also, in the case
of IOTA, the idea is-- well, they don't call
it this-- but it's the equivalent of saying
every block must have one and only one transaction.
The transactions themselves have proof of
work on them, and they point to each other,
which, basically, is the same as blocks have
one transaction, and you do the work yourself
instead of paying a miner to do it.
I think that's not a great deal. And they
say that that means there's no fees. I think
there's still fees. Because you're just doing
the work yourself. I think that's equivalent
to saying, there is a refrigerator at Home
Depot that doesn't use electricity. So hey,
it's electricity-free. But there's a crank
on the back, and you have to crank it to make
the refrigerator cold.
Yeah, you could make a refrigerator that way.
I don't think people would want it. You're
still doing the work. You just have to crank
it instead of plugging in it. So the idea
of you don't have to pay miners a fee to get
into a block because you just mine the block
yourself or, in this case, you mine the transaction
yourself. Doesn't seem that useful.
Anyway, so IOTA's fun. We talked about them
a while ago. OK. Last one, and it's fun--
proof of idle. It's an old idea that I wrote
up four years ago, almost. It probably doesn't
actually work that well. But a lot of these
things don't work that well. Even if it works,
it would just move the costs from opex to
capex.
But what you do is you prove that you're not
mining, and you get paid. And the other fun
thing about this is it led to some of the
ideas in Lightning Network. So the idea is,
in Bitcoin, the difficulty adjusts so that
blocks come out every 10 minutes, right? Every
2016 blocks, you look at the timestamps, adjust
the difficulty.
So new miners coming in make it harder for
the existing miners. So if you're a miner,
you really don't want anyone else to start
joining this network and mining. You really
like it as it is. So if you have the first
ASICs, you're good, and you don't want everyone
to come in.
And this is why so many people buy mining
equipment and lose money. Because they look
at the current difficulty, and they say, hey,
here's this device. Here's how much electricity
it uses, how many coins it generates.
This is profitable. I'm going to buy this
thing. And what they don't realize is that
by the time they actually get it, or maybe
a few weeks later, the difficulty is doubled.
And now it's making half as many coins for
the exact same amount of electricity.
So yeah. And that's a fairly unique property
of bitcoin that's not the case in, say, gold
mining or other extractive industries. There's
some kind of curve in gold mining where if
you pay twice as much money to have twice
as many people dig holes and mine gold, you
won't get twice as much gold. Maybe you'll
only get 10% more gold. But you will get some
more, right? And if you drill for oil, you
pay twice as much, you'll get some more. But
yeah?
AUDIENCE: And it's worse than that. Because
you're still obligated to mine. Because making
$0.50, they're making half as much as they're
going to make, it's still better than making
nothing.
TADGE DRYJA: Yeah. So that happens, too. So
yeah, in Bitcoin, two times the mining leads
to 1X the coins mined, right? There is zero
marginal product of labor in this system,
which is weird and counterintuitive and doesn't
really exist in normal life.
Most things have some kind of sublinear curve,
where, yeah, the first low-hanging fruit--
if you're mining coal, and you start in Pittsburgh,
and it's just sitting there on the hill, and
you're like, hey, that was easy. And then,
eventually, you have to start open pit mines
and digging holes. And it's expensive, and
you don't get as good. But you still, if you
double your effort, you're going to get some
extra stuff out.
Then again, there might be cases, I'm sure,
in economics, where eventually, it goes negative,
where if you continue adding members to an
organization, eventually, they're just like
deadweight, and they make it less efficient
or something. But in Bitcoin, it doesn't matter
how much you mine. You always get the same
number of coins.
So the obvious thing there is, well, we should
all just stop mining. And then we'll have
zero electricity usage, and we'll still get
the same amount of coins.
AUDIENCE: The example is Nobel prizes. It
doesn't matter how many academics chase them,
there's a unique number [INAUDIBLE].
TADGE DRYJA: OK, yeah. Yeah, that's another.
Yeah. However good the science is, you just
get one Nobel Prize. So OK. So let's say there's
two miners. And there's, obviously, more.
And they're each mining with 2 gigawatts.
And they both think, well, wait. If we both
turned our mining down 5%, we'd still get
the same amount of coins, but we'd be using
5% less electricity. We should have a meeting,
maybe some kind of cartel.
So this is sort of OPEC, right? This is a
classic cartel. If we all restrict our output,
we can raise prices and reduce our costs.
In Bitcoin, it's the perfect cartel environment.
Because if we all reduce our output, we get
the same output, sort of, right? If we all
turned down mining 50%, we all still get the
same number of coins. The network still works
fine. Maybe nobody even knows we're doing
this. This is ideal cartel scenario.
Problem for cartels, generally, is that cartels
are hard to maintain, especially when there's
not a lot of trust. Because there's so much
profit in defecting and going against the
rules of the cartel. And OPEC has this all
the time, where one of the OPEC countries
says, we're just going to pump a bunch of
oil and sell it. Because everyone else reducing
their output raises the prices. And now we
can sell more with higher prices.
So in this kind of system, if all the miners
said, hey, let's all turn down 50%, the one
miner who then mines at full blast is going
to make a lot of coins. So this is the problem.
In Bitcoin, nobody trusts anyone, right?
So the solution here is trustless collusion.
And in the papers, I was like, well, is it
collusion or cooperation? They both sort of
mean the same thing. And collusion is just
a bad word for cooperation. Cooperation's
good. It's on Sesame Street.
OK. So the basic system is Alice pays Bob
not to mine. So first thing, Alice needs to
prove that Bob can mine. Because she doesn't
want to pay Bob if Bob doesn't have any mining
capacity that he's taking offline. She only
wants to pay Bob for having the ability to
mine and then not doing.
So A posts a block header at a specified time
and says, OK, B, mine for 10 seconds, and
give me your 100 best shots, right? So in
Bitcoin, you have this fixed difficulty. And
you just say, OK, anything below this block
hash is valid.
But you could make one where you say, hey,
give me your best 100, and I can then extrapolate,
or interpolate, from that what your hash rate
is. And you can get pretty accurate. So they
have to do some work, right?
Bob does some work but for a brief period--
I don't know, 10 seconds. You don't want latency
to be an issue, so maybe 10 seconds, maybe
a minute-- whatever-- some small amount of
work to prove that they have the capability
to do the work. They respond with that. And
Alice validates it and says, OK, you've got
X amount of work capacity.
Alice then creates a 2 of 2 multisig transaction
and sends one bitcoin to this address and
builds two transactions with Bob. This is
sort of like, how Lightning Network looks,
Lightning Channels. But this predates it by
a year or two.
So the idea is you've got this funding, and
then you've got two transactions. They're
both signed by both parties and held by both
parties, although in practice the one that
pays out to Alice, Bob doesn't really need
to store. He doesn't like it. And the one
that pays out to Bob, Alice doesn't need to
store.
But the idea is they have conflicting locktimes.
So in the transaction header, you can have
a locktime, say, OK, this transaction is only
valid after this point. So the one that pays
Alice is height plus 144. So the current height
of the blockchain plus 144, well, that should
take about a day, right? If blocks come out
every 10 minutes, 144 blocks is one day.
For Bob, Bob gets a coin with the current
locktime plus 24 hours. So in Bitcoin, you
can specify either Unix time or block height.
And I think everything above 500 million is
a time. Everything below 500 million is interpreted
as a height, which means this whole system
runs out in a couple thousand years.
So this is a race, right? There's two transactions.
One of them can be broadcast first, depending
on how fast blocks come up. So if blocks come
out very quickly, this will be valid first--
144 blocks. Maybe it only takes 20 hours,
and these 144 blocks have come out. And Alice
can post this transaction and get all of her
money back, get her one coin back.
However, if blocks come out slowly and, after
24 hours, only 120 blocks have come out, Bob
can post this transaction first. And it will
be valid and confirmed, and Bob gets the coin.
So now Bob's incentives are, well, I'd like
144 blocks to take longer than 24 hours. Because
then I'll get this coin.
And Bob has the means to influence this, right?
Bob's a miner. So Bob can say, well, I'll
just mine less. And if I mine such that, in
24 hours, only 130 blocks come out, I get
the coin. Cool, right?
If blocks come out fast, on the other hand,
Alice gets her money back. So Alice has no
real risk here that Bob will run away with
the money without doing his part of the job.
So Bob can slow down his mining in order to
get the bounty coins. If Alice estimates incorrectly
how much profitability Bob has, Bob just keeps
mining. Alice gets her money back. This collusion
didn't occur, at very little cost, right?
Bob had to prove a little bit. There's some
coordination costs. But basically, nobody
loses the money.
So Alice can put whatever bounty she thinks
is beneficial to her. OK, I'll pay you three
coins not to mine as much. And you can chop
this up. You can have a lot of different,
smaller transactions and make a curve. If
you mine a lot less, I'll pay you more-- things
like that.
Yeah. So that's the idea behind proof of idle.
It feels like it might happen, to some extent,
long-term. It feels sort of like nuclear weapons,
where everyone's got them, but they don't
really use them. They just threaten.
So it feels like mining could be that kind
of thing, where, well, we've all got all this
mining capacity, but we just threaten each
other with it, and we don't really mine. Because
the mining's actually really expensive, and
it's just the threat of mining that you need.
And if someone tries to do, say, a 51% attack
and reorg, the existing mining infrastructure
can spin up and say, oh, no. You thought you
were 51%. You were actually 5.1%. And we're
90% offline. And we all come back online and
reorg you out.
It's an interesting-- I think it's a fun idea.
In practice, it doesn't work now because it's
mostly capex. So this doesn't help if your
main constraint is building the chips, which
it sounds like it still is, from David's talk
on Monday, right? Yeah, you need to get electricity,
sure. But also, the really big problem is
getting a supply of all these chips.
And this would just exacerbate that. This
would make it so that I don't even need electricity.
I just get the chips. I don't really care
how much I'm paying in electricity because
most of the time, my chips sit off. I just
need to occasionally prove I have them and
have the ability to mine with them.
So it wouldn't solve the problem of proof
of work in terms of people spending tons of
money on it. But it would move it towards
less electricity usage, more fabrication plant
usage. Is that a good thing? Is that a bad?
I don't know.
And in certain cases, it may be that it saves
people money. It may be that, hey, if we can
collude in this way, actually, we save money.
And then we can use it to build more hash
power.
So this might happen. I was sort of convinced
in 2014. I'm like, oh, I think this is going
to happen. I also thought that it would become
predominantly opex in 2015 or '16. And it
just didn't-- not even close. So who knows?
But it's, I don't know, kind of a fun idea.
OK. So in general, lots of new ideas out there.
Proof of work does seem to work. But I think
one of the big issues is it's not really compatible
with the Kurzweil/Roddenberry future idea.
Has anyone read Ray Kurzweil, like, Age of
Spiritual Machines?
It's sort of this futurey AI is going to make
everything great, and we're all going to live
forever, and computers are going to be our
best friends, and we're going to take over
the universe. And Gene Roddenberry of Star
Trek is sort of a popular, not quite as crazy--
maybe just as crazy-- view of that.
In Star Trek, they don't have money. They
just sort of explore the universe and make
the world a better place and stuff like that.
And it's like, cool. And there's a lot of
people who are into technology and research
who are, maybe not consciously, but identify
with these ideas, like, yeah, we're making
the world a better place. Computers are going
to help people, and it's going to be great.
And I think one of the issues with Bitcoin
and proof of work is it doesn't fit into that,
right? It's sort of dystopian, in a way. And
then, it's like, wait. We're going to have
giant server farms performing SHA256 for the
next 50 years? Like how? How does the benevolent
AI fit into this system?
So that's one of the reasons people-- the
proof of idle idea was-- I was at University
of Virginia, and Avi Shalot, who's now at
Northeastern, he was like, I hate Bitcoin.
Because the whole point of SHA256 is that
you can't find collisions. That was the design--
collision-resistant hash function.
And now, you've built this giant system, which
the whole point of the system is to find collisions.
Like, ah. That's the opposite of what it was
supposed to be. And so it was just sort of
inelegant and ugly. And that was where I'm
like, well, maybe you don't really have to
mine that much. And so I wrote this thing
about proof of idle.
But anyway, that's one of the issues that
people have with proof of work. And that's,
I think, one of the big motivating factors
for all this other research into different
consensus algorithms. And further research
is required, maybe.
The interesting thing is a lot of the people
doing proof of work are fine with it, right?
So like David, Monday, he's not interested
in proof of stake. Despite the proof of work
ecosystem being so crazy, he's just like,
nope, this is what I'm doing.
So none of the miners are interested-- I mean,
miners, their job is to mine. So they're usually
not interested in proof of stake. And then
Bitcoin, in general, a lot of it's like, no,
this seems to work. We're OK with it. This
is the cost we're willing to bear.
But other people want to do other systems.
So further research is required, or not. But
it's happening. There's tons of research into
different consensus mechanisms. I would say
in academic research, that's the biggest thing.
What I would like to see more of is more academic
research in proof of work. Because there's
a little bit, but there's all sorts of interesting
things with proof of work where it's like,
oh, something like proof of idle or something
like the stuff David was talking about on
Monday. There's not much economics research
into this.
And I think it's a really interesting question,
where you've got, hey, I've got a device that
prints money, and I want to sell it to you.
What? How does that work in terms of economics?
How much should I sell it for? How much should
I buy it for-- things like that. So there's
a lot of new research into new proof of stake,
different consensus mechanisms, economics
that way and not as much into new forms or
how proof of work works, which I think is,
actually, really interesting.